they've taken photographs of me and sort  of morphed them into this frightening  reptilian looking creature the look is  his bald head and long spindly fingers  sort of like a skeleton  they've got it's like the veins on his  hands and on his arms and eyes on his  head they just add to the whole element  of kind of fear and creepiness that goes  with him it's great it's really good  he's outrageous and he's really  frightening sometimes he's really kind  of mad  gone somewhere else in the eyes  [Music]  ray finds was our first choice uh  frankly our only choice getting the  inability to inspire such fear with so  little clearly her to be charismatic and  be someone who'd inspired many to follow  him